wie ist ihre Reaktion auf diese Urteile
ja diese Urteile lassen uns natürlich an
die alten Zeiten erinnern
ich muss aber sagen dass in der späten
Sowjetunion unterbrechen auf gab es
solche Urteile für Worte nicht es ist
wichtig zu verstehen dieser Urteile
verurteilen frei gesprochene Worte
sadima karamusa ist unter anderem wegen
hochverratsverurteilt aber unter diesem
Hochverrat versteht man die Kritik der
russischen Staates
in üblichen Ländern in demokratischen
Staaten gibt es dafür keine Strafen und
wir können sehen wie man ganz frei und
ganz hart in den meisten Ländern der
Welt die Regierung kritisieren kann
natürlich eine hohe Strafe aber das ist
egal ob das fünf oder 25 Jahre sind das
ist inakzeptabel das heißt dass die
Regierung Angst vor Worten hat das ist
eine schwache Regierung und wird
scheitern
was bezweckt der Kreml mit diesem und
den anderen urteilen
eigentlich wenn man die Sachen beim
Namen nennt dieser Urteile sind nicht
weniger als Terror das ist ein Versuch
die Gesellschaft einzuschüchtern ein
Versuch die
Gesellschaft dazu zu bringen dass es
den Anweisungen da macht folgt das ist
offensichtlich
und unter Druck stehen nicht nur die
Prominenten
Oppositionellen aber auch ganz einfache
Menschen
die einfach Ihre Kritik geäußert haben
das macht man dafür damit jeder Mensch
unsicher wird und Angst hat frei zu
sprechen
das wird aber kein langfristigen Effekt
oder Wirkung haben
herakinski wir haben hier in Deutschland
das große Glück in einem Land zu leben
in deinem indem man seine Meinung frei
äußern kann und gerade in dieser Sendung
sind für froh über die Kommentare und
die Fragen unserer Userinnen und User
deshalb möchte ich die auch gerne mit in
die Sendung einbeziehen wenn Sie oder
Ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt dann
schreibt sie in die Kommentare oder per
Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und ich gucke mal ein
bisschen welche Kommentare schon
gekommen sind hier gibt's sehr viel
Anerkennung von den Userinnen und Usern
einer schreibt über Youtube wow sie sind
noch in Moskau das ist mutig und ein
User hat die Frage haben Sie keine Angst
verhaftet und abgeurteilt zu werden mit
einer fingierten Anklage
das ist eine seltsame Frage natürlich
gibt es diese Gefahr und diese Gefahr
ist aktuell für alle die nicht
einverstanden sind mit der Position der
Regierung aber selbst der
regierungsmeinungsumfragen zur Folge der
themensprecher des Korf hat sie zitiert
ungefähr 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind
mit der heutigen Politik nicht
einverstanden das sind Leute die keine
Angst haben in der Meinung zum Frage das
zu sagen das heißt ich bin nicht der
Einzige
das haben auch die
Gerichtsverfahren gezeigt ganz viele
Leute sind zu diesen Verfahren gekommen
obwohl das ein Arbeitstag war und die
Zeit war ungünstig wenn man einen Job
hat und in dieser Gericht in dieses
Gerichtsverfahren zu gehen und es gab
ganz wenig Platz im Gerichtssaal nicht
destotrotz hunderte von Menschen sind
hingekommen da sind Leute die
offensichtlich
nicht einverstanden sind mit der
Regierung das heißt es gibt noch
Oppositionelle in Russland
es sind nicht weniger geworden
und sie glauben auch dass sie sich nicht
weiterhin davon einschüchtern lassen
wenn es solche Urteile wie diese in
dieser Woche gab 25 Jahre Straflager als
Urteil als drohendes Urteil für mögliche
Oppositionelle
Resüme Hitze
natürlich das ist unangenehm und
natürlich will niemand hinter Gittern
landen
aber man kann auch an das folgende
denken es gab auch Zeiten in Russland
als man nicht nur die Gefahr der
Haftstrafe hatte sondern die Gefahr der
Todesstrafe aber selbst damals gab es
Leute die keine Angst hatten nicht
einverstanden zu sein danke diesen
Leuten ist die russische Gesellschaft
sie will Gesellschaft noch am Leben
danke diesen Leuten gibt es die
Tradition der Freiheit in unserem Lande
deswegen denke ich dass es diese
Verbindung
immer noch gibt diese Kette wird nicht
reißen
das ist sehr wichtig
für die meisten Menschen manche
verstehen das aber nicht ganz gleich
es gibt hier wenn ich in die Kommentare
gucke sehr sehr viel Zuspruch und
wahnsinnig viel Respekt davor was sie in
Russland tun ein User schreibt über
Youtube danke an die mutigen Menschen in
Russland hut ab vor ihnen allen lassen
sie uns auf Ihre Arbeit blicken auf das
was
Memorial tut wir fassen das kurz
zusammen
dezember 2022
janradschinski nimmt als Vorsitzender
von Memorial den Friedensnobelpreis für
Russlands älteste und bekannteste
Menschenrechtsorganisationen zusammen
mit menschenrechtern aus Belarus und der
Ukraine
Memorial setzt sich seit 1988 für die
Aufarbeitung von politischer Verfolgung
und für Aufklärung über die
menschenrechtssituationen in Russland
ein dort ordnet der Oberste Gerichtshof
Ende 2021 die Auflösung der Organisation
an weil Memorial gegen das Gesetz für
sogenannte ausländische Agenten
verstoßen habe
ja wie können sie denn unter den
jetzigen Bedingungen überhaupt arbeiten
also
wie ich bereits erwähnt habe
diese Situation ist nicht die
schrecklichste im Vergleich zu dann
Zeiten die unser Land im 20 Jahrhundert
erlebte und natürlich dieser
Friedensnobelpreis sollte an akzene
reginski an den ersten Vorsitzenden von
Memorial gehen
er hat an eigenem Leibe erlebt was
Depression heißt er saß in einem
Straflager obwohl es für ihn die
Möglichkeit gab das Land zu verlassen
aber er hat entschieden im Lande zu
bleiben das war seine Wahl ja und wer
arbeiten weiter warum diese Arbeit
brauchen tausende und Millionen von
Menschen
nicht unsere Laune das zu machen das ist
eine Notwendigkeit
das ist notwendig für viele Menschen
Zielen möchten von den Schicksalen ihren
Verwandten erfahren viele möchten über
die Schicksale ihrer Familie erfahren
das ist eine Notwendigkeit die von der
Regierung nicht zerstört werden kann
das heißt unsere Arbeit wird gebraucht
das ist die Erinnerung Arbeit der
Erinnerung an die Repression der
Vergangenheit und das Wissen über
Menschenrechtsverletzungen heutzutage
das ist für uns in Memorial
zwei Sachen die miteinander verbunden
sind wir verstehen was die
Taten von Vergangenheit waren und wir
sehen was die Spuren von diesen Taten in
der Gegenwart sind und sobald man das
noch braucht wenn wir das fortsetzen
nun gab es zuletzt auch Durchsuchungen
bei Ihnen und in den Räumen der
Organisation unter dem Vorwand perfider
Vorwürfe lassen Sie sich davon
einschüchtern
in diesem Fall lasse ich mich davon
nicht einschüchtern das war
wahrscheinlich gerade das Ziel
aber diese Vorwürfe sind tatsächlich
perfide
diese
uns wird vorgeworfen
Nationalsozialismus
zu rehabilitieren zu versuchen und das
sagt man an die Menschen die genau den
Gegenteil tun wir haben uns damit
befasst die Erinnerung an die Opfer von
Nationalsozialismus wach zu halten bevor
der Staat das gemacht hat zum Beispiel
die
Zwangsarbeiter viele von uns haben
unsere Verwandten im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg verloren viele von
unseren Verwandten haben in dem Krieg
gekämpft das heißt diese Vorwürfe sind
tatsächlich perfide und falsch
und das ist das macht uns keine Angst
aber er Empörung
hier kommen viele Fragen an Sie einen
User möchte wissen wie es die allgemeine
Stimmung in Moskau merkt man eine
Anspannung in der Gesellschaft wie
nehmen sie das wahr
schwer zu sagen man hat nicht genug
Informationen
mein Freundeskreis mein Bekanntenkreis
ist jetzt nicht so groß dass ich
allgemeine Schlussfolgerungen sehen kann
man fühlt natürlich diese Spannung warum
ja es gibt
fernsehpropaganda und diese Propaganda
im Fernsehen ist viel aggressiver als du
denn so wird Zeiten es gibt
hasswert verbreitet und ein großer Teil
der Gesellschaft
ist in einem psychologischen Zustand der
Hysterie und da sieht man in
verschiedenen Formen
und natürlich ist es dann nicht
verwunderlich dass es diese Spannung
unter den heutigen Bedingungen gibt wenn
man das beobachtet was gerade läuft das
ist nicht verwunderlich
eine andere Frage beschäftigt sich mit
der Präsenz der Opposition in Russland
Chris fragt werden andere Politiker
außer Putin überhaupt wahrgenommen
das ist eines der Hauptprobleme in
Russland wir haben praktisch keinen
politischen Raum
wir haben keine Diskussion
Diskussionen die ihr Gesellschaftsfragen
betreffen würde
das alles wurde vernichtet
man hat die Wahlen gefälscht dafür man
hat die
Wahlgesetze dementsprechend novelliert
und jetzt ist es zum Beispiel unmöglich
als Beobachter bei den Wahlen zu
arbeiten alle
Oppositionellen Politiker sind verbannt
des Landes oder auch sitzen im Gefängnis
oder überhaupt keine Möglichkeit haben
die Gesellschaft anzusprechen
das macht die Situation sehr schwierig
und unvorhersehbar
eine Userin namens Amy Mac fragt oder
sagt ich finde es so mutig in Russland
zu bleiben wie halten Sie das aus
ja das halten viele Menschen aus wir
bereits gesagt 20 Prozent die in den
Meinungsumfragen offen erklärt haben die
sind mit der Politik der Regierung nicht
einverstanden da sind Millionen viele
Millionen von Menschen
natürlich es ist sehr schwer
das
Geschehnisse zu beobachten es ist
sehr schwierig mit
keiner Meinungsfreiheit zu leben ohne
demokratische Freiheiten aber wir sind
immer noch da wir arbeiten weiter wir
versuchen weiter einerseits die
Erinnerung an die Vergangenheit war zu
heißen zu erklären was ist in der
Vergangenheit gab und auch die Gegenwart
zu erklären ich glaube den Menschen die
hier geblieben sind sie lernen ganz viel
gerade jetzt zusammenzuarbeiten
zu koordinieren das ist für die
Regierung sehr unangenehm aber genau das
rufen sie mit ihren Begrenzungen hervor
stellen Sie sich vor es gibt keine
Möglichkeit in der Zeitung im Fernsehen
im Radio zu sprechen in dieser Situation
suchen diese Menschen nach
Gleichgesinnten so entstehen diese
gesellschaftlichen und dieser Prozess
kann nicht gestoppt werden
sagt der Vorsitzende von Memorial in
Moskau Jan raczinski vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren und
alles Gute für Sie